el papá francisco está avergonzado este
miércoles desde el vaticano el jefe de
la iglesia católica abordó la revelación
de que cientos de miles de niños fueron
abusados sexualmente por figuras de
autoridad de la iglesia en francia
decide el exprimer l 20m quisiera
expresar a las víctimas mi tristeza mi
dolor por el trauma que han sufrido y
también vi vergüenza nuestra vergüenza
ni vergüenza por la incapacidad durante
demasiado tiempo de la iglesia de
ponerlas en el centro de sus
preocupaciones
la nostra perdón ya la mía ver hoy
la comisión independiente reveló que 216
mil menores sufrieron abusos sexualmente
por parte del clero católico francés en
las últimas siete décadas esta cifra
aumenta a 330 mil si se incluyen a las
figuras de autoridad católica como
maestros y consejeros la gran mayoría de
las víctimas eran niños preadolescentes
el arzobispo el aaiún afirmó que la
mentalidad de la iglesia de protegerse
primero a sí mismo debe cambiar hubo una
especie de voto de silencio que se
remonta a lo que dije sobre la cuestión
de las mentalidades
básicamente era una época en la que la
gente no veía o no quería ver estas
cosas pero sobre todo en la que el
primer reflejo era proteger a la
institución
para los miembros de la iglesia la
magnitud de los abusos ha sido
devastadora político detrás de las
cifras hay vidas creo que debemos
tomarnos el tiempo necesario para
escuchar lo que se ha dicho lo que se ha
revelado este informe ha sido esperado
por mucho tiempo
y de hecho este tipo de actos llevan
demasiado tiempo produciéndose y se
habla poco de ellos tendría que haber
habido muchas reacciones hasta el
principio de la conferencia episcopal de
francia ha pedido perdón el papá
francisco pidió a todos los obispos que
tomen las medidas necesarias para evitar
más abusos en el futuro